je vous demande d'accueillir isabelle
comme il se doit
non
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
l'affût mais les plus vrais que nature
ça ne veut pas de ça n'aurait pas vu des
rappeuses comme ça olala ça c'est la
cerise sur le gâteau là je trouve que ça
vous va pas mal à ce qui me tue de rire
c'est ça montre suisse et le drapeau
suisse vous pourriez faire un petit robe
pour voir comment est ce que vous
rappeler comment ma forme je sais pas où
je sais pas ramener les carottes et de
rap au septième art est une ennemie mais
lorsque je trouve que ça vous va super
je vous assure
franchement ça ne va pas super bien
aller avec la fouine a laissé un petit
duo tous les débats ressemblent à des
danseuses sur mes clés oui
non mais franchement y avait là peut pas
faire un petit rap tous les to dépouille
je veux bien mais si tu veux me crasher
je te réponds pas qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait les faire chanter
ils sont prêts à chanter plus chirac est
ce que tu pourrais me bats et quoi qu'on
me reçoit marc lavoine j'aimerais que tu
me rappelles a les yeux revolver en
rappaz est pas mal pas mal
bonne idée je veux mettre toute les
intonations elle a les yeux l'anti
préval mmes du piment à la une fait
j'aime bien les yeux revolvers volés pas
voulu venir à côté de moi tous les deux
comme ça mais ça ce matin
mais la tendance les caméras mais c'est
la première fois de ma vie que je vois
un jeune la basket ball
mais
bâti au nom et oui c'est le maillot de
nicolas tôt bon alors les yeux revolver
elle a généré la première la faute et
c'est foutu
isabelle faut savoir je vous aime d'un
amour infini vous êtes et rendez vous
c'est je crois qu'elle est prête pour
les anges de la télé réalité